as a little kid you were born into a
household and you had a backpack on and
your dad kept dropping bricks in that
backpack and a couple times your mom and
your dad put cinder blocks in that
bag and you've been carrying that sucker
around not to mention your boyfriends
and those breakups and the stupid thing
that your girlfriend told you one time
and your own things that you've
experienced right and now how old are
you 28 28 with a backpack that weighs
5,000 lbs and it's so
heavy
and instead of taking the bricks out of
your backpack and just setting them down
I'm not carrying this
anymore you're hunched over trying to
hold this thing up and your legs are
shaking and your shoulders are burning
and you're looking at your mom asking
her why she put them in there that's who
I mean she
did there will never be an answer that
takes the weight off of your back that's
your job that's your adventure to go do